burritos burritos folded terrible open
shake it
we're looking at a big dildo
today we're finding the best fast-food
drive-through breakfast I look like I'm
Way more fresh because you're wearing
pajama I don't look red
I mean you're in pajamas they're very
nice pajamas I'm just never mind I feel
like I'm wearing a tuxedo or something
excuse me what is your idea of a perfect
breakfast eggs and bacon for sure I
would say either over easy or scrambled
with some turkey bacon throw avvocato on
that plate maybe some coconut pancakes
whoa with a cup of jail you're just I
don't know the menus that we're gonna
see today but I doubt any of that
something
yeah hey Carl's everywhere so here's the
deal guys you guys are each gonna pick
one thing you share with each other and
we're gonna pick something to throw in
the mix and it has to be from the
breakfast yeah can we have a quick
minute please all right they got the
Grande scrambler all hope the thing yeah
it does all like the POW I like the
shape of the Crunchwrap I'm gonna do the
Grande scrambler can I get us was it 17
17 18 and 19 please bacon sausage
favorite California you said California
what's California
at key block people Wow
did you want to do that instead let's
see this one California let's keep it
simple okay thank you
yo this is the best idea ever I'm so
excited you know this here is yours
yay first of all love the shape I'm not
a breakfast burrito breakfast taco guy
in general this is so good
yeah yeah we should try it I watched
your face as you ate it and there was no
expression at first and then very so
surprised
I think that California is like a good
move it tastes like really authentically
breakfast taco yeah oh god this is good
I like that crunch - is that bacon in
there how many more thank you
so the guac and pico is a really nice
taste yeah California a.m. right here I
go
the burrito burritos okay it's a little
bland I mean there's nothing exciting
about it that one really stands out but
I think Californian Pico works okay
should we stop yeah just one no it tells
everything it's not bad mmm but I think
with the California style it adds that
extra element of like oh we're in the
southwest the thing is the breakfast
food is like so full of salt this is
just like a salt stick to me that with
the guac great the guac is refreshing it
like cuts all the salt and so it kind of
has the balance okay yeah I'm gonna take
that back overall this exceed your
expectations of what Taco Bell
breakfast is this for sure did yeah I'm
thoroughly surprised you think about
Taco Bell and you just think of like
3:30 a.m. drunken binges that you don't
remember but you wake up kasi with
rappers all around you with this
breakfast it adds a new life it's
actually tastes pretty good there's a
great hangover food yeah I inhaled that
thing next stop is a chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a have you guys ever had
chick-fil-a breakfast no I never got
chick-fil-a breakfast oh there's only
like three or four cars in front five
six seven eight nine that's two lanes
all right you guys got breakfast oh
sweet Canadia spicy chicken on a biscuit
oh we could do spicy chicken in this -
yeah just the meat and the bread yeah
I'll do the ball just get the chicken
biscuit with egg and cheese there you go
now I got egg falling from my wrists say
I'm gonna give me a fork son Oh use your
hand got my damn hands me yeah Gus okay
yeah
this is all I want look at that
yeah this is chicken I don't know it's
not exciting because I think chick-fil-a
is they really lean on the quality of
their chicken when I bite into the
chicken aw it's amazing but like
everything else is just kind of man I
really like mine because their biscuits
this is fluttery I love it you know most
eggs taste like spongy or like no that's
not real but this tastes like they
straight-up cracked it this is like
really fresh a sec this is way better
than talked about I still think the Taco
Bell breakfast is an elite overall
flavor-wise it's more complex there's
more things going on it's just a block
about the only 1/4 of us want to
everyone you're so damn good I don't
even like business yeah this is a great
combo it's really it's complimentary for
spicy and the buttery and the texture
between like the crisp and the slight
and lush same thing that you Gobbo egg
and cheese but look at the amount of
like egg they are not sleeping on the
egg they really go ham I just don't need
all that big old piece of chicken thick
old piece of egg all right here we go
does it make a difference tastes like
America we're talking biscuit we're
talking fried chicken or talking eggs
and and cheese and it's all just very
streamlined straight to freedom town
that's why I got this plane is cuz like
chick-fil-a they freaking know their
chicken that's all you need you don't
need all this extras as that everybody
else gets it's not bad
I mean chick-fil-a is a solid place so I
wouldn't expect their breakfast to
disappoint me you know what you're
getting it's okay it tastes good but I
feel like I would get bored of it after
a while it's every once in a while it's
like that like really supportive like X
that you have that's like nice but like
not that interesting so overall you know
it's not gonna last but they're really
nice people and they're supportive let's
just keep comparing the food to our exes
I think so we've been driving for 40
minutes and now we're finally off the
highway after a good nap where we had it
we're going to sonic sonic baby
hi yak I'm just gonna do breakfast stuff
yeah I'll do a toaster but the bacon can
I get a sinister some french toast ick
I'm good do you guys have something
swear your food yeah I think there's
some cine sticks or the French toast
sticks it's probably french toast sticks
and then this is the weird you guys got
a snacks that doesn't look that bad the
bread looks good
this is bro okay they have the right
texture this is actually pretty good
this is the third place we've been to
and this is actually legit looking eggs
they threw up on the fryer I think it
could have been a little more cheesy
overall it's a good balance breads kind
of plain but it tastes like what you
would make at your house which makes me
feel better doesn't seem like this
pre-made assembly line kind of food that
looks like me definitely just heated it
up anyone try y'all can finish that I
don't really want those like a funnel
cake all right Oh weird if I don't get
anything on that one there we go that's
a real dip big dip energy that's not bad
yeah you guys want to try these in a
stash what is in it it's basically a
Cinnabon with cinnamon and filling and
then cream cheese dip whoa this makes me
feel like it should sound like there's
really good good the sin of filling
sounds gross to me but it's not too bad
they're mushy and they look like egg
rolls I think that this sonic has been
better than you you thought oh my god
burritos burritos folded terrible like
I'll open that's the part you know
yeah it looks like a little alien
wailing in the wind a lot of bacon way
more bacon
so I'm majority bacon well it's if you
like bacon but yeah there's like nothing
else there's extremely fine final
thoughts what do you think Taco Bell is
my favorite if I ever have to do
fast-food breakfast time do that
California style all the way
Taco Bell is my favorite that's number
one I have the more complex flavors and
veggies and guac and all those other
things but it wasn't probably the
freshest eggs maybe ingredients per se
as far as the egg cheese bacon combo but
overall as a whole as a flavor
experience Taco Bell I would say
chick-fil-a was great but it only really
just had chicken and then sonic was a
big ol waste of time but the sonic
though I did like the French toast the
French toast sticks are good yeah and
they say anything so you guys this thing
is Taco Bell Taco Bell win let us know
if you have an idea for this if you
think that we're hideous and we went to
the wrong places and if you have an idea
of your own and you think that we should
try and that's a cut
[Music]
you